pressekonferenz aus anlass des treffens
von bundesinnenminister seehofer mit
seinem österreichischen kollegen näher
aber wir beginnen mit zwei kurzen
eingang statements von se minister
seehofer wird beginnen im anschluss
haben sie die möglichkeit fragen zu
stellen
ich bitte schon jetzt um verständnis
dass wir wegen des zeitplans von
ministern haben wir diese
pressekonferenz um 17 uhr beenden werden
wenn es damit meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen liebe kalt ich freue
mich über den besuch wir hatten ihn
schon mal vor einigen wochen anvisiert
dann kann man's carola dazwischen und es
ist deshalb für uns wichtig weil wir mit
unseren österreichischen nachbarn eine
ausgesprochen gute zusammenarbeit
pflegen also praktisch störungsfrei
das hat sich besonders gezeigt in den
corona bedingten grenzkontrollen die wir
in den letzten wochen und monaten hatten
die sind ja in der durchführung nicht
ganz einfach bei der vielfalt der
lebenssachverhalte die wir beide erlebt
haben und wo dann immer wieder politisch
nachgesteuert werden muss dass es bei
der frage was ist ein triftiger grund
für die grenzübertritte zu keinen
größeren problemen kam
ich habe
dem kollegen gedankt für die
zusammenarbeit der sicherheitskräfte an
der grenze so wie wir ohnehin eine
wirklich exzellente zusammenarbeit haben
zwischen der republik österreich und der
bundesrepublik deutschland
zweitens will ich darauf hinweisen wir
haben in der gesundheits lage etwa die
gleichen herausforderungen mit auf der
einen seite kontakt beschränkungen auf
der anderen seite das noch schwierigere
prozedere zu lockerungen lockerungen
sind immer schwieriger als die
einschränkungen aber wir teilen beide
die ansicht dass zu dieser
gesundheitslage möglicherweise in den
nächsten wochen auch eine
sicherheitslage kommt wir haben es ja
hier besonders am letzten wochenende
erlebt nicht nur in stuttgart sondern
beispielsweise auch in göttingen mit
abstrichen auch in berlin
ich treffe heute noch den gesundheits
den inneren sinn hat davon
berlin wir haben gleiche
herausforderungen mit quarantäne blöcken
die sicherheit durch die polizei zu
gewährleisten wir hatten in stuttgart
diese geschichte also ich habe heute im
kabinett auch berichtet ich wünsche es
mir nicht aber wir müssen damit rechnen
dass in den nächsten wochen und monaten
zu dieser gesundheitslage auch eine
sicherheitslage kommt wo wir auch als
innenminister noch besonders gefördert
gefordert sein können
und das dritte große thema das wir
besprochen haben ist die zukunft der
migration
wir rechnen ohne dass wir sehr beiräten
wollen in den nächsten monaten wieder
mit einem ansteig anstieg der
zuwanderungszahlen wir sind ja da im
gleichen boot
gerade was die balkanroute betrifft
österreich und deutschland und deshalb
legen wir höchsten wert darauf dass wir
endlich in europa ein gemeinsames
regelwerk bekommen dass die migration
ordnet die migration für die eine in
ordnungssystem schafft auf der anderen
seite auch die humanitären fragen
vernünftig beantwortet schaut im moment
so aus dass felder in unsere
ratspräsidentschaft hier am ersten juli
beginnt die deutsche präsidentschaft
dass die kommission und die zuständige
kommissarin wohl den vorschlag der
kommission für eine gemeinsame
asylpolitik in europa erst nach der
sommerpause und damit nach der klärung
der finanzen in europa vorlegen wird
das ist für uns dann eine stramme
herausforderung in unserer
präsidentschaft wenigstens eine
diskussion so zu führen dass wir ende
des jahres und damit zum ende unserer
präsidentschaft zu bestimmten
politischen einigungen kommen können
auch wir stellen uns dieser aufgabe
es hat mich sehr gefreut dass du heute
schon mal öffentlich erklärt hast dass
du dich mit dem gedanken künftig die
entscheidung wer schutzbedürftig wäre es
nicht schutzbedürftig an der außengrenze
auch treffen möchtest nach
rechtsstaatlichen regeln vom
schnellverfahren wollen wir bei hynix
wissen es müssen zügige verfahren
rechtsstaatliche verfahren sein und es
muss verbunden werden mit der
beantwortung der frage der zurückweisung
von der außengrenze in die
herkunftsländer auch mit anreizsystemen
die die zusammenarbeit mit den
herkunftsländern verbessern und wir
beide legen auch wert darauf dass es
einen legalen weg in die europäische
union geben muss das ist das dritte
element um ihre arbeit aufzunehmen und
nicht den umweg über das asylsystem
wählen zu müssen
und wenn man diese schlüssel frage
geklärt hat in europa dann kann man die
folge frage angehen nämlich nach welchen
regeln werden die schutzbedürftigen in
europa verteilt die diskussion leidet
gelegentlich darunter dass manche den
zweiten schritt vor dem ersten machen
wollen und dann kommt man immer ein
stolpern in dem man erst die
verteilungsfrage lösen will
und dann erst die schlüssel frage was
geschieht an der außengrenze das ist mir
sehr wichtig und auch das gespräch jetzt
hat gezeigt dass wir hier wohl gemeinsam
marschieren in dieser grundfrage danke
nochmal er werde jetzt anschließend noch
zu den gesundheitsminister fahren und
alles gute ist eine haben heute vielen
dank wir haben eine sehr geehrten damen
und herren es freut mich sehr dass wir
diesen besuch nachholen konnten
es war ein guter und intensiver
austausch es war auch getragen von
meiner seite als innenminister der
republik österreich mit einem großen
dank an die bundesrepublik deutschland
an horst seehofers innenminister an die
polizeibehörden sowohl der länder als
auch des bundes weil wir gemeinsam eine
sehr herausfordernde zeit zu meistern
hatten und noch immer auch haben
corona virus ist ja leider noch nicht
besiegt aber gott sei dank
einigermaßen unter kontrolle in unseren
beiden staaten und in vielen anderen
jetzt gott sei dank schrittweise auch
mehr
und diese krise hat auch tatsächlich
gefordert wir haben eine lange und gute
nachbarschaft und es hat sich bewiesen
dass es sich lohnt und auszahlt eng
miteinander zusammenzuarbeiten ein gutes
gesprächs verhältnis zu haben die
behörden haben intensiv miteinander
jetzt kommuniziert es gab ganz viele
herausforderungen zu lösen die aufgaben
sind menschlichen bereich lagen wo man
individuelle lösungen für die
betroffenen finden musste und gott sei
dank auch großteils gefunden hat dafür
auch von meiner seite ein großes danke
und gleichzeitig gibt es eine große
übereinstimmung in der frage welche
herausforderungen uns jetzt nach der
überwindung zumindest aus der ersten
phase des corona virus ist und jetzt
gleich wieder begegnen und dazu zählt
natürlich auch das thema migration ich
hatte intensive kontakte jetzt mit den
innenministern aus serbien bosnien
herzegowina nord mazedonien kroatien
griechenland ungarn alle die die auf
besonders von dem thema migration
betroffen sind österreich verfolgt da
eine 3 sicherheitsnetze strategie was
verstehen wir darunter das erste
sicherheitsnetz ist der eu-außengrenze
und daher volle unterstützung für die
betroffenen länder griechenland spanien
italien die der besonders gefordert sind
österreich hat das auch ausgedrückt
indem wir eine spezialeinheit entsendet
haben nach griechenland mit einem
gepanzerten fahrzeug um die griechischen
einsatzkräfte im höhepunkte krise als
die türkei die europäische union
provoziert hat menschen vorgeschoben hat
um mit ihrem leid politik zu machen hier
die griechischen behörden direkt an der
grenze zu unterstützen das wurde sehr
gut aufgenommen als zeichen der
sichtbaren solidarität genau das wovon
minister seehofer gesprochen hat nämlich
dass wir einander solidarisch beistehen
auch in einer herausfordernden zeit und
darüber hinaus haben wir gesagt es
braucht einen massiven eu-außengrenze
aber auch immer hilfe vor ort also wir
haben nicht nur polizeikräfte entsendet
sondern auch unmittelbar geholfen mit
dem urin hat er aber auch direkt indem
wir 181 wohnungs an der container
griechenland zur verfügung gestellt habe
damit das leiter betroffenen vor ort
möglichst rasch gemildert wird die
griechische regierung ist sehr engagiert
und sehr bemüht und gleichzeitig passt
es eben sehr gute initiativen und ich
bin sehr dankbar jetzt auch für die
ratspräsidentschaft der bundesrepublik
deutschland und da für die initiative
von dir lieber horst zu dem thema eu
außengrenze schnelleres oder schnelles
und gut qualitativ gutes asylverfahren
das ist uns beiden wichtig und richtig
so rechtsstaatlichkeit muss die
grundlage sein und gleichzeitig aber
auch diese initiative wichtig um zu
zeigen dass es möglichkeiten geben muss
sich mit dem thema irregulärer migration
und lösungen dafür auch tatsächlich zu
finden
österreich ist davon besonders betroffen
weil das zweite sicherheitsnetz von dem
ich gesprochen habe ist dass der
grenzschutz der balkanstaaten und der
dritte dann das dritte sicherheitsnetz
unser eigener grenzschutz aber
entscheidend ist ja dass wir es
überhaupt gar nicht so weit kommen
lassen sondern jetzt wege finden um uns
mit dem thema intensiv
auseinanderzusetzen damit
unkontrollierte ihre lehre migration
sowie wie sie 2015 in dramatischen
bildern erlebt haben und noch beide
staaten massiv betroffen waren nicht
mehr erleben sie müssen sich vorstellen
österreich hat seit 2005 10
200.000 asylanträge zu bearbeiten gehabt
wir haben 100 10.000 menschen schutz
gewährt in dieser zeit und das ist für
ein kleines land wie österreich 8
millionen einwohner eine tatsächlich
große herausforderung wenn sie an die
relation ist gerade auch zur
bundesrepublik deutschland denken um
hier den sozialen frieden stabilität und
vor allem auch integration zu
bewerkstelligen und zu ermöglichen
das heißt auch das thema wie kann man
legal nach europa nach österreich kommen
haben wir in österreich versuch mit der
rot-weiß-rot-card aufzulösen das heißt
wir haben einen prozess definiert wie
man regulär legal nach österreich
einwandern kann und auch arbeiten kann
das unterliegt ganz bestimmten
bestimmungen
das soll jetzt teil der diskussion sein
wo man auch von einander wechselseitig
lernen kann ich bin nochmals sehr
dankbar für diese initiative freue mich
auf die weitere zusammenarbeit und jetzt
auf ihre fragen
vielen dank herr stempel hat die erste
frage herr minister nie haben wir wenn
sie sagen sie unterstützen minister
seehofer bei seinen plänen migration auf
eu ebene sind sie auch bereit
flüchtlinge dann aufzunehmen die dann
quasi in den anker zentren dort also an
der eu-außengrenze von dort aus in den
europäischen ländern verteilt werden
sollen sowie das ist so rasche
und zweitens sprechen sie dann auch mit
an orban und mit ungarn das die dann
auch bereits und flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
also insofern die frage ob sie den
minister auch da unterstützen und herr
minister seehofer an sie die frage des
klang grad so als hätten sie sich bei
der frage klage gegen eine taz
journalisten noch nicht entschieden
können sie da sagen wann sie sich
entscheiden ob sie es bereuen weil sie
auch jetzt auch merkt man der zwar
vielleicht ein bisschen voreilig von
diesen planungen der klage zu reden und
welche rolle hat er die kanzlerin
gespielt also zum einen österreich ich
glaube ich gerade vorhin deutlich
ausgeführt hat schon sehr viele menschen
aufgenommen und sehr vielen menschen
schutz gewährt alleine auch schon 2009
10 wieder 2000 asyl antragstellungen
gehabt und auch da laufen die verfahren
österreich leistet hier einen der
grössten beiträge innerhalb der
europäischen union sie können sich gerne
mit den zahlen dann vergewissern ich
lasse in diesem zusammenhang gern immer
die fakten sprechen dass österreich im
verhältnis zu anderen europäischen
staaten in der europäischen union einen
übergroßen beitrag dazu leistet dass
menschen die auf der flucht sind und den
schutz gewährt werden muss auch
tatsächlich schutz gewährt wird und dann
sind wir auch schon bei dem ersten punkt
in der innenminister seehofer ja
angesprochen hat zunächst einmal ist die
frage zu gern schaffen wir es uns
außengrenzen asylverfahren zu
verständigen und schauen wir ob es auch
tatsächlich funktioniert welche
wirkungen und konsequenzen es hat auch
schneller tatsächlich danach rück
weisungen möglich sind und müssen uns
auch gelingt dieses bittere und übrige
geschäft organisierten kriminalität
durch die
lebewesen nachhaltig zu zerstören weil
die menschen sehen dass es eben nicht so
einfach ist und nicht sinn macht sich
auf den weg zu machen weil es eben dazu
einen grund braucht wenn man um asyl
sucht aber genauso auch das ist legale
möglichkeiten gibt sowie minister
seehofer gesagt hat einen weg zu finden
nach europa zu kommen und dort zu
arbeiten ich glaube das sind die
wesentlichen voraussetzungen und daher
stellt sich die frage für uns und das
ist hier wie sie wissen auch die
position der republik österreich derzeit
die frage nach der verteilung nicht weil
österreich wie gesagt einen bis jetzt
auch schon und den vor allem andauernden
hohen beitrag leistet wenn es darum geht
menschen schutz zu gewähren
ja stempfle ich möchte jetzt für den
augenblick sagen wir haben es damit
keine petitesse zu tun sondern einer
wichtigen frage oder mehreren wichtigen
fragen und deshalb muss man hier auch
sehr sorgfältig vorangehen ich bin
einmal in der frage verfassungsminister
gefragt nämlich der frage was wir im
umgang miteinander uns gegenseitig auch
unter berücksichtigung der verfassung
der meinungsfreiheit pressefreiheit
zumuten wenn wir miteinander umgehen und
das zweite ist die position des
innenministers wo ich eine fürsorge und
schutzfunktion für die polizei in der
bundesrepublik deutschland habe und
diese fragen sorgfältig auszuleuchten
es für mich wichtig ich begrüße auch
ausdrücklich debatten die darum
entstanden sind
ich möchte auch nicht dass die debatte
mit irgendeinem tag beendet wird sondern
wir müssen diese debatten des
zusammenlebens in deutschland
miteinander diskutieren
auch die rolle der polizei in unserem
lande
die polizei ist für uns ein ganz
wichtiger hüter eines stabilen
rechtsstaates und deshalb muss auch
diese frage mit diskutiert und geklärt
werden wie wir mit unserer polizei
umgehend das weiß ich von der polizei
und zwar von allen landespolizeien und
bundespolizei dass ihnen dieses
verhältnis und die klärung dieses
verhältnisses sehr wichtig ist wenn ich
ihnen meinen heutigen tag sage dann
haben sie vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
verständnis dass ich mich nicht jede
stunde mit der frage und ihrer
umfassenden lösung beschäftigen kann ich
hatte heute ein normales kabinett
digital kabinett anschließend dann
bundessicherheitsrat dann jetzt den
besuch der österreichischen delegation
dann habe ich anschließend ein gespräch
mit dem berliner innensenator kaiser
wegen auch solchen fragen aber
insbesondere wegen des
antidiskriminierungsgesetzes in berlin
wie wir damit umgehen wenn die
bundespolizei dort im einsatz ist das
haben wir auf der innenministerkonferenz
verständigt und dann kann ich ihnen
nicht die uhrzeit sagen war nicht damit
mein kerngeschäft an diesem tag beenden
kann und dann kann es sein dass ich
heute dann noch endgültig die dinge
entscheidet aber ich bitte das jetzt
nicht als alarmmeldung zu verstehen es
kann auch sein dass sie erst morgen im
laufe des tages dazu komme das hängt
wieder davon ab wie das morgen alles
abläuft wir sind ja immer noch auch mit
der abteilung unvorhergesehenes
konfrontiert das ist kein kein wegducken
vor der sache das ist kein zeit
verzögern sondern solche geschichten die
ich als so bezeichnet habe es dass es
keine petitesse ist fordern große
sorgfalt und ich möchte auch dass wir
intensiv über den kern der sache
diskutieren nämlich über diese
verhältnisse die ich vorhin genannt habe
unter dem gesichtspunkt
verfassungsminister unter dem
gesichtspunkt innenminister ich hoffe
sie haben dafür verständnis
die nächste und auch letzte frage hat
der kollege in der vierten reihe mit dem
hellen sakko vielleicht können sie kurz
sagen wir für wen sie arbeiten
hinterland zdf an minister seehofer die
jüngsten cholera ausbrüche sind ja vor
allem bei sozial schwachen aufgetreten
denken verhältnissen ist kubys links zu
einer sozialen frage geworden und wie
wirken sie wie wirkt die bundesregierung
dem entgegen hat man das in der
vergangenheit vielleicht auch versäumt
sie ich habe vielleicht von den aktiven
politikern die meisten solcher krisen
szenarien durchlebt als
gesundheitsminister als
landwirtschaftsminister als bayerischer
ministerpräsident und ich kann ihnen
sagen
im mittelpunkt steht um ist der besuch
von dir entspannt so wichtig einfach
dass man bei einer bei einem solchen
infektionsgeschehen weltweit die
infektionsketten erstens identifiziert
ist ja auch nicht immer so einfach wie
sie in den letzten stunden erlebt haben
und zweitens sie radikal unterbricht
wenn es ihnen nicht gelingt die
infektionskette zu unterbrechen wäre es
wird es ihnen auch nicht gelingen die
das infektionsgeschehen früher sprach
man ja von solchen in den griff zu
bekommen das ist für die kleinen
verhältnisse für die sozialen probleme
das wichtigste das geschehen in den
griff zu bekommen um auf die
unterstützung der bevölkerung nicht zu
verlieren und dann tun wir als deutsches
kabinett eine menge von der schonung der
mieter bis zum kurzarbeitergeld bis hin
zur unterstützung der frauen bei der
kinderbetreuung um diese sozialen fragen
auch gerecht zu beantworten und da muss
man immer wieder nach steuern weil wir
wie bei dem was wir jetzt an der grenze
gemeinsam erlebt haben die
lebenssachverhalte dermaßen vielfältig
sind dass sie immer wieder von
bestimmten kreisen zu recht darauf
hingewiesen wird uns gibt es auch noch
die schausteller zb die künstler die
dann oder mittels kleine mittelständler
solo unternehmer die uns dann schildern
welche sorgen sie
begleiten und da müssen sie als
politiker bereit sein zu helfen und es
tut glaube ich die deutsche regierung
schon sehr sehr konsequent auch unter
dem gesichtspunkt der gerechtigkeit also
da bin ich jetzt sage ich man muss immer
selber prüfen kann man mit den
ergebnissen leben ist man mit sich
selbst im reinen bei dem was man tut und
da muss ich ihnen sagen dass jetzt kein
selbstläufer regierung wir machen auch
unsere fehler und es ist nicht alles
ganze ideal aber ich glaube dass wir
bisher eine sehr gute antwort auch unter
diesem gesichtspunkt gegeben haben
die letzte frage geht jetzt noch mal
einen kollegen vom orf minister haben
wir österreich hat eine reisewarnung für
nordrhein westfalen herausgegeben
betrifft das auch so quasi ein
einreiseverbot von menschen aus diesem
bundesland und wie wir diese
reisewarnung oder was hat das für
konsequenzen und herr minister seehofer
was sagen sie dazu dass das gute
verhältnis mit österreich durch solche
reisewarnungen möglicherweise getrübt
wird und wie handhabt das bayern mit die
wollen ja auch keine nordrhein westfalen
in bayern auf urlaub haben
fange ich auch gerne also die
reisewarnung ist immer ausdruck ja auch
eine einschätzung eine entwicklung einer
situation wir können jetzt alle die
dramatischen ereignisse und sind alle
zurecht glaube ich besorgt man muss
genau hinschauen deutschen behörden
unternehmen jetzt alles um genau das zu
tun wovon minister seehofer gesprochen
hat und was wirklich so unendlich
wichtig ist dass man rechtzeitig und
schnell die infektionsketten durchbricht
und ein erfolgreiches containment
betreibt was bedeutet die reisewarnung
die reisewarnung heißt eben achtung wenn
man sich in dieses gebiet aufmacht und
das heißt auch für menschen die aus
diesem gebiet kommen die
eigenverantwortung zu leben und sich
sozusagen darüber im klaren sein wenn
man symptome hat oder wenn man sich
unsicher fühlt 14 50 anrufen sofort eben
danach trachten dass man getestet wird
und warten bis das ergebnis vorliegt und
sie nicht weiter in der öffentlichkeit
zu bewegen also all das was wir erkennen
sie wissen wir haben in österreich jetzt
schritt für schritt
alle zwei wochen die einschränkungen
zurückgenommen so weit es möglich ist
und statt der einschränkung gilt jetzt
noch viel mehr als vorher dass
eigenverantwortung jetzt von den
bürgerinnen und bürgern geleistet wird
und da bin ich zuversichtlich dass das
gelingt ja wir hatten ja früher das
heißt vor jahren sollen in den letzten
wochen eigentlich immer eine nationale
lösung
und wir sind ja schritt weil sie dazu
übergegangen mehr regionale lösungen
hotspots zu beantworten
mit jetzt lokalen einschränkungen
ich habe im leben kann
die bitte mit gegeben wenn das die
strategie ist in einem land das man
regionale abgrenzungen macht und nicht
ein bundesland oder die ganze
bundesrepublik deutschland zu überlegen
ob man dann auch reisewarnungen so
lokalisieren kann dass man sich auf die
hotspots konzentriert und nicht darüber
hinaus
das ist eine bitte die ich hiermit gebe
auch für den bundeskanzler weil die
österreichischen freunde ja
oft auch sehr dafür geworben haben dass
wir deutschen nach österreich kommen
nachdem wir das ja wirklich sehr
begrüßen dass meine jetzt wirklich nicht
erotisch könnte es eine lösung sein es
könnte auch eine europäische lösung sein
wenn wir regionale hotspots haben nicht
mehr gleich grenzkontrollen einzuführen
das machen sie auch nicht sondern sich
dann auf die beschränkungen dieses
regionalen hotspots zu konzentrieren
beim tourismus kann man das relativ
einfach über die beherbergungsbetriebe
das machen wir in deutschland auch dass
es bundesländer gibt die sagen
aus diesen regionen bitte keine
touristen
ich glaube das ist bis auf weiteres so
lange das alles relativ gut im griff
bleibt eine eine vielleicht sogar
zukunftsträchtige antwort die würde uns
nämlich wenn man sich in ganz europa
darauf verständigt in die lage versetzen
ja die die beschränkungen und die
kontrollen auf diese hotspots zu
konzentrieren und generäle
grenzkontrollen zu vermeiden
das wäre aber wie gesagt das habe ich
als bitte mit gegeben weil jetzt auch so
hin fragen so entschieden werden müssen
dass sie für die zukunft europäisch
gehandhabt werden können
meine damen und herren ich bedanke mich
für ihr interesse und beendet diese
pressekonferenz